hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
franz kafka's short story inside the
penal colony raises some some very
important questions about justice
punishment sentencing what's right and
wrong
a number of moral issues as applied to
criminality and violence that is
being done to people and one of the most
central aspects of the story indeed
something that you could say the story
in fact
revolves around almost a character in
the story
is the machine and the machine
is supposed to do one task it's supposed
to
inscribe justice inscribe
a punishment on the naked body
of the person who is going to be killed
by the machine
in the end so you could say
in a certain way that the machine is
a representation of the will
not of justice per se but of the
former commandant and the officer
a character who's in the story who so
identifies with him sort of like the
apprentice or the
you could say the the follower the
um executor of the will
of the former commandant and it's
important to remember too
that this machine is an innovation it's
not
something that goes way back into their
tradition and histories
this is only one generation old and it's
it's something that they invested a lot
of time
and money into as a priority
in this this penal colony we should also
mention too a penal colony
is a prison colony everybody who's there
presumably
is there as a prisoner in one way or
another
and this machine develops you could say
out of a mindset as far as we can tell
because
as usual with kafka's stories we're
getting
narrations and histories that we can't
entirely
trust and only reveal to us part of the
picture
but sketch an entire world there are
some ideas some really basic ideas about
justice
that are being embodied in the machine
in which bodies are being placed so
one of these ideas is of punishments
fitting the crimes that when somebody
commits a violation
what is done to them as a
response somehow corresponds to
what it is that they did sometimes we
talk about poetic justice
for example when somebody who cheats on
somebody else is cheated on
in turn and we can say oh well you had
it coming to you
so the machine is embodying a certain
kind of
you've got this coming to you
although as we see when we look at the
the
account of what's going on the
prisoner who is condemned in this case
hasn't gone through any sort of judicial
process
they're just ordered to get into this
machine and they don't actually
know what's going to be happening until
later on
the other thing that that is
directly tied to this and you see this
in a number of
treatments of justice and punishment
is the idea that punishment shouldn't
just be
brutal it shouldn't just wipe somebody
out
it shouldn't just you know be revenge
enacted on them
part of the process of justice
should lead to the punished person
understanding the wrong that they did
and perhaps even understanding that what
is being imposed on them
is in return just so you put these two
ideas together punishment fitting the
crime
and the punished person understanding
the wrong
that they did and the rightness of the
system and there's a lot of ways in
which you could work this out you
wouldn't
necessarily need a machine like this as
a matter of fact
this machine may be a bad
way of carrying that out but this is
what is decided upon
by the commandant and the amount of
both work and expense on the one side
and thought on the other shows that this
was not something entered into
very lightly this is an attempt to try
to produce
justice on earth so it's it's kind of a
you know you might say a representative
of enlightened schemes of penalty
and punishment in order to understand
this
we have to look at how the machine
actually works
and kafka provides us with a good bit of
discussion about this
in in the way that uh we could say that
the explorer
is having the story told to them by
the officer who is also invoking the
previous commandant as this you know
almost saintly or or sage-like
figure right he he's explaining to the
explorer what's going on
there's three big components to the
machine there's a bed
that the prisoner lays upon and the bed
is going to vibrate
and also turn the prisoner and it's got
a
cotton wool as we would say cotton balls
or things like that to catch the blood
which is is going to be issuing from the
prisoner's body
there's the designer the top part which
like the the bed contains an electric
battery and that goes over them and then
within the bed there are the the
what's called the harrow but it turns
out it's actually multiple harrows
and each of these is a piece of glass
that contains needles within it
and the two kinds of needles the needles
that will pierce the flesh
of the prisoner and needles to spray out
water to wash the blood away and there's
i mean we can imagine that there's
hundreds or thousands
of these needles within the harrow
so the bed vibrates and the arrow comes
down
onto the prisoner onto their naked flesh
and starts
poking them and at first as they point
out
when somebody first goes into the bed
the harrow is lowered onto its body it
regulates itself automatically so the
needles barely
touch his skin once contact is made the
steel ribbon stiffens immediately into a
rigid band and then the performance
begins and notice that this is not
just when he says performance it's not
just
for the prisoner himself it's also for
the potential onlookers
there were spectators at this according
to
the officer when the previous commandant
was in charge people would come to it as
a judicial spectacle
and watch the sentence being carried out
so what is the sentence what what what's
the need for all of this apparatus
as they summarize it whatever
commandment the prisoner has disobeyed
is written on his body so you know this
doesn't actually sound that bad when you
put it just like that
they're you know laying down they're
stuck there and whatever rule they broke
of the penal colony or could be also you
might say a moral rule
as well we don't actually know because
we don't have a list
of these rules and we in fact just get
two of them
as examples in the story but whatever it
is
it's effectively tattooed on their body
not even using ink so you can say well
that doesn't sound
like a terrible sentence somebody kills
somebody and then maybe a tattoo thou
shalt not kill on their head
and you're like well there you go i
don't do that anymore
or you know thou shalt not steal maybe
it's in big big letters
and maybe the needle goes deep so it
really you know drives the the message
home well it's not that simple
the idea is that the needles
are going deeper and deeper
into the prisoner's flesh the story
talks about
there being multiple passes so at first
it's just tiny little pinpricks
and then the needles are going deeper
and deeper and deeper
into the person's flesh and eventually
there's going to be a
spike that's going to come down right
into their head and kill them so this is
a
fatal procedure there there is no
non-corporal
punishment uh well it's not not just
non-corporal that all this is corporal
non-capital punishment i meant to say
there is no non-capital
punishment with the machine perhaps
there could be in other cases
but this is the one that that it seems
that the former commandant really
liked so these needles go deeper and
deeper into their flesh and then
the idea of the machine is able to be
enacted because it's not just about
making somebody
suffer all of these pinpricks which
would be a terrible thing
but if you did that then we wouldn't get
this
idea of the punishment fitting the crime
because everybody's punishment would be
more or less the same wouldn't it it
wouldn't have any
distinctiveness to it and it certainly
wouldn't
lead the punished person to realize
anything so a little bit later on here
we go
around the sixth hour after six hours
of just pain the the
officer says that there is a
new experience that takes place
enlightenment
comes to the most dull witted it begins
around the eyes
from here it radiates a moment that
might tempt one to get
under the harrow oneself a little bit of
foreshadowing there
he says nothing more happens than that
the man begins to understand the
inscription
he purses his mouth as if he were
listening
you have seen how difficult it is to
decipher the script with one's eyes
but our man deciphers it with his
wounds to be sure that is a hard task
he needs six hours to accomplish it by
that time the hero has pierced him quite
through
and cast him into the pit then the
judgment has been fulfilled
so what's the idea here over
this period of time because of the way
in which the needles are piercing
one's body almost like as if somebody is
writing
letters on your skin i just did an a
right there
but you know is this a cue is this a g
is it's a
p i i don't really know but presumably
you'd be paying very close attention
as this is happening there comes a point
where the prisoner
begins to realize this is lettering
this is telling me something i can like
pay attention to it
and figure out what is actually being
written on me
and then when the prisoner realizes what
the
sentence is the imperative
they realize what they did wrong and now
they're ready to pay the ultimate
penalty for it to be to be killed
so that's the way the machine works
according to the officer
whether it really does that or not
that's that's an open question that we
have to explore
we should also think about the designs
of the inscriptions because that helps
us to
approach that question so
they contain one central imperative
that has been violated so in the case of
the officer
when he himself gets into the machine
the piece that he brings out
says be just and you can think of this
as sort of like a template
or you know data that's going into the
machine to guide it
in the case of the prisoner who is
originally
there um he is caught
you know not doing his his duty
and so um what it what is his his
sentencing well he's going to
have um i'm trying to get the exact
wording essentially it's obey your
superiors right
and so presumably if the man is in there
eventually he'll realize oh
that's what i did wrong and
the the imperative you could you know
think back well when did i do that was
it yesterday was it the day before
in this case it would be very easy
because he fell asleep on century
duty and then was insubordinate to his
superior
and presumably there would be an entire
set
of these templates that would correspond
to
the commandments that were written down
somewhere
in the penal colony so they contain
one central block of lettering
now here's where it gets very
interesting
they're surrounded by all these
embellishments
and they involve a complex script
now why is that
the case so
as as the officer is going to say we
we want this to take quite a while
right we want this to um
we want this to lead to a sort of
enlightenment
here we go so this is the scene where it
happens
he takes out some sheets from his
leather wallet and says i can't let you
handle these these are my most
precious possession i'll let you see
these he spread out
the first sheet of paper the explorer
would have liked to say
something appreciative but all he could
see was a labyrinth
of lines crossing and re-crossing each
other
which covered the paper so thickly it
was difficult to discern the blank
spaces between them
the officer says read this check it out
and the explorer says i can't make out
anything here
and the officer says oh it's it's clear
enough it's very ingenious
and then the explorer says i can't make
it out and so he puts it away
and says it's no calligraphy for school
children it needs to be studied
closely i'm sure that in the end you
would understand it too
so it's not something that's immediately
evident
it's not like there's just a template
that says be
just or obey your superiors or don't
steal food or
treat your fellow prisoners well or
anything like that
it's just like a mess of stuff and you
gotta like
really know what you're looking for in
order
to find the injunction
or the imperative that is part of this
inscription
why so the the officer tells him
the script can't be a simple one it's
not supposed to kill a man straight off
but only after an interval of on an
average 12
hours but the turning point is reckoned
to come at the
sixth hour so there have to be lots and
lots of flourishes around the actual
script the script itself runs around the
body
only in a narrow girdle the rest of the
body
is reserved for the embellishments
and there's you know another scene where
he takes out the
the officer takes out the one that is
going to apply to him
himself shows it to the
explorer the explorer says yeah i can't
make out that one either
so all of this embellishment
is really kind of you know it's serving
some sort of purpose within the scheme
of the machine
but it's in a certain sense inhumane
it's adding to the suffering
all of these extra things and
you know who is it legible too so
we know that it's legible to the former
commandant because he's the one who came
up with this
he's the one who did everything the
officer can read it
according to the officer the explorer
can't read it
the question that remains is
can the condemned person actually read
this with their body the
officer says well we need all these
embellishments because it's got to take
up all of this time
and produce this state of enlightenment
but what is being registered on the body
as he says
the inscription goes in just a narrow
band the imperative
that has been violated by the person and
that they're supposed to recognize
all the rest of the body is being
pierced with
needles and induced into
horrible pain which you would think
you know as we reflect on this
wouldn't that be sort of the equivalent
of noise
preventing the the signal or the message
from coming through
how does one concentrate on just one
portion of a body that is being
subjected to torments
how do you zero in on that particularly
if you're
not a smart person or attentive person
or body conscious person to begin with
which is the way that the
explorer and the the officer are
presenting these these prisoners
maybe this is one suggestion
the machine is inscribing something on
the person
but maybe there isn't any enlightenment
that's taking place
maybe this is really something that the
commandant hoped for and the officer is
projecting
on to people that are being subjected to
this this machine
maybe it's impossible to truly
fulfill these things in a physical way
by
inscribing a message upon a person
through
the agency of needles and the medium
of pain in the flesh
that's a big issue that's being raised
here
maybe there's an ideal of justice whose
application
turns out to be terrible injustice
and cruel inhumane not just
at all maybe that's why
the officer himself subjects himself to
the last running
of the machine
you